je m'appelle Aziza j'ai 12 ans à la
maison je dois faire tout le ménage et
mes frères ne veulent jamais m'aider
c'est pas juste bonjour je m'appelle
Aziza j'ai 45 ans et je trouve toujours
que c'est pas juste
[Musique]
nous sommes en 1990 Aziza a 12 ans et à
la maison c'est elle qui doit faire le
ménage pour ses frères elle venait à la
télévision pour dire c'est pas juste je
suis vraiment pas d'accord parce que non
seulement je dois faire des ailes mais
en plus je dois faire leur ménage 30 ans
plus tard on l'a retrouvé du côté de
Marseille et elle vous raconte ce
qu'elle est devenue alors c'est pas
juste c'est une émission qui était un
peu à son summum dans les années 90 qui
passait sur France 3
donnait la parole à des enfants qui
venaient dénoncer une injustice qui
avait l'air d'être un peu personnel mais
au final qui mettait le point sur des
phénomènes de société en fait le matin
je dois faire la vaisselle quand ma mère
travaille du matin
l'après-midi vers 2h je vais jouer au
volley et le soir je dois faire la
vaisselle je dois m'occuper que la
maison soit en ordre mais en fait tout
bêtement j'avais j'avais écrit à
l'émission parce que Ben à l'époque je
trouvais injuste de pas avoir de cadeaux
de Noël parce que ben ma maman elle a
élevé seule 4 enfants elle était
aide-soignante elle travaille la nuit
donc c'est vrai qu'il y avait pas
forcément beaucoup de budget pour les
cadeaux de Noël et on m'a demandé de
réfléchir s'il y avait pas autre chose
que je trouvais injuste et puis ça m'est
venu d'un coup j'aurais dit bah
spontanément ah oui à la maison mais
c'est moi qui dois faire le ménage et là
ça les a ça les a immédiatement
intéressés et ils sont venus à ma
rencontre par contre ça se fait que ce
soit toi qui t'occupes de tout ça
il trouve toujours une excuse il
travaille alors à l'époque j'avais trois
frères trois grands frères et moi
j'étais là la dernière la seule fille je
pensais beaucoup que ce sentiment
d'injustice il était lié à ça parce que
j'étais la seule fille qu'est-ce que tu
détestes le plus dans le ménage quelle
est la tâche qui te
[Musique]
de voir
faire le ménage dans la chambre de mes
frères
parce que c'est pas moi différent alors
là je suis vraiment pas d'accord parce
que non seulement je vais faire mais en
plus je dois faire leur ménage ils ont
pas plus fait la vaisselle mais ce que
moi j'ai pas su exprimer c'est pas tant
de d'être Cendrillon je passais pas des
heures et des heures à faire la
vaisselle mais c'était cette
responsabilité qu'on retrouve finalement
au quotidien pour pour beaucoup de
femmes de se dire tiens faut que je
fasse les courses en rentrant faut que
je pense à poster le chèque de
l'électricité enfin les petites choses
qui font que on n'est pas totalement
libre d'esprit
aujourd'hui j'habite Marseille donc dans
les Bouches-du-Rhône et je suis
infirmière libérale infirmière à
domicile
[Musique]
cette double casquette de me dire venir
boire un café chez Marie-France c'est un
soin au même titre que lui mettre un
médicament dans la bouche un
antidépresseur mais bien sûr plus
[Musique]
ça seul visite on crée on crée des liens
vraiment vraiment fort vraiment
particulier on est là avec eux du lundi
au dimanche à Noël à Pâques à leur
anniversaire et c'est vrai que
maintenant je me vois pas faire autre
chose
quelque chose
à l'époque l'émission elle a vraiment
rien changé à mon quotidien ni dans ma
relation à la famille ni avec les
voisins ou les copines d'école je veux
dire voilà je suis parti à l'école on
m'a dit on t'as vu le soir à la télé
mais sans plus finalement les lignes
elles ont pas beaucoup bougé c'est un
sujet que moi je pensais
culturel ben oui il y a mes origines
maghrébines forcément finalement c'est
tout le bassin méditerranéen finalement
je les ai mis dans le Nord c'est
exactement pareil
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Sylvia je suis la
maman à Aziza
[Musique]
elle pense que c'est le travail d'une
fille de faire ça vous pensez que le
rôle d'une fille c'est d'être une
j'allais dire une femme de ménage je
pense qu'il y a le droit de la fille
pour quelque chose il y a quelque chose
aussi à faire que la fille soit à faire
quelque chose
[Musique]
ménagères tant qu'elle est petite elle a
des choses à faire
des petites des petits rôles à faire
mais est-ce que vous imaginez par
exemple rentrer à la maison un soir et
voir Elias par exemple en train de
passer l'aspirateur c'est mon rêve
ça c'est mon rêve je comprends bien que
ma mère travaille et que elle rentre
elle est fatiguée elle a pas le temps de
des fois elle a pas le temps de préparer
à manger elle rentre tard le soir alors
il faut bien qu'on se débrouille par le
propre moyen
mais c'était très archaïque mais ma mère
elle avait quand même
de la modernité en fait finalement quand
elle vous dit mais c'est mon rêve que
que mon fils il rentre il est en train
de faire le ménage elle est surprenante
dans ses réponses mais finalement
c'était hyper moderne comme point de vue
vous étiez donc seul à la maison avec
vos enfants en fait c'est simple vous
les avez élevé toute seule quoi
ma maman je pense qu'elle voulait
me donner les armes pour être une bonne
une bonne femme une bonne mère une bonne
épouse mais elle m'a surtout donné les
armes pour être indépendante en fait ils
savent le faire
mais ils veulent pas le faire
vous avez qu'à faire vos vaisselle
vous-même si chacun lave son assiette et
plus vite il dit ça mais ça sert à rien
elle sera mal faite comme ça donc c'est
moi qui dois faire le sel non non mais
c'est vrai je reconnais que c'est Aziza
qui faisait plus de trucs de ménage
c'est un travail un travail de
verbalisation à faire parce que ma maman
finalement elle s'était pas rendu compte
qu'il y avait il y avait un peu de
souffrance quand même qui avait un peu
un côté isolement et il faut en parler
en fait c'est c'est déjà le début du
travail pour faire bouger les choses
mais non maman tu rigoles ou quoi je
rigole c'est devenu
si vous avez des enfants plus tard
est-ce que vous retombez dans les mêmes
pièges
ce serait aussi à la fin d'y faire mais
ce serait pas pour la même réponse ce
serait parce que j'en ai vraiment eu
marre d'y faire quand j'étais petite
alors je m'attendais pas forcément à
avoir deux garçons je pense que c'est
une chance parce que je suis pas dans ce
dans ce conflit un peu de peut-être que
j'aurais voulu préserver ma fille ne pas
reproduire ce que moi je pensais avoir
subi et alors moi j'aimerais bien être
un garçon pour ne pas avoir à faire les
tâches ménagères comme j'ai retrouvé
l'archive je l'ai immédiatement montré
aux garçons en fait il connaissait pas
du tout cette histoire c'était ravie de
me voir en fait de découvrir leur maman
presque à presque à leur âge quoi ils
ont ils ont 9 ans et 7 ans donc il y a
peu d'écart par contre aujourd'hui les
garçons c'est hyper important garçon ou
Marie et puis c'est naturel de toute
façon qui met à la pâte qu'on me
soulager moins en tant que maman mais
aussi pour leur pour leur avenir quoi
c'est pas parce que tu es une fille que
tu dois faire deux fois plus de travail
manuel
par exemple sur
nettoyer tout ce qui est propreté c'est
pas juste alors c'est vrai qu'on a des
règles de vie des règles de vie commune
mais le plus important en fait c'est de
de faire attention les uns aux autres
je me suis rendu compte que c'est une
question de société en fait et ça quand
je l'ai revu 30 ans après ça m'a
vraiment
revalorisé en fait c'est bien j'étais un
peu féministe à l'époque enfin je trouve
que c'est super d'être engagé à 12 ans
de prendre la parole et de dire c'est
pas juste et c'était pas que mon combat
que je menais et j'espère que ça a pu
dans certaines familles ouvrir le débat
chez moi ça l'a pas fait mais ma
situation elle n'était pas grave j'étais
dans une famille
solide structurée donc l'essentiel
l'essentiel était là mais je pense que
ça a pu ouvrir le dialogue chez
certaines familles